[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
schöne Weihnachten wünsche ich euch wir
sind ja gerade mittendrin und falls ihr
jetzt vielleicht noch spontan ein
leckeres Tiramisu zaubern wollt dann
habe ich heute ein perfektes Rezept für
euch ein Spekulatius bärentiramisu könnt
ihr auch gerne zu Silvester zubereiten
oder die ganze Winterzeit über denn das
ist immer sehr sehr lecker ich zeige
euch mal die Zutaten ich starte direkt
mit der Fruchtfüllung und da jetzt
gerade keine Beeren Saison ist greift
ihr am besten auf Tiefkühlprodukte
zurück und ihr könnt entweder einen
Bären Mix nehmen da ist immer so alles
drin Anwalt Bären oder ihr müsst euch
die Bären selber zusammen denn ich
persönlich zum Beispiel mag
Johannisbeeren nicht so gerne in so
einer in so einem Bären Mix deswegen
möchte ich mir das jetzt aus drei
Früchten selbst zusammen dafür verwende
ich 100 g Zucker und jeweils 250 g
Blaubeeren Himbeeren Sauerkirschen alles
aus dem Tiefkühlfach etwas Tonka Paste
und eine Orange davon nehme ich dann den
Saft mein Buch fällt da oben
vollständig gut als erstes nehmt ihr
jetzt den Zucker der kommt hier direkt
in der Pfanne bei mittelhoher Hitze und
darf schon mal karamellisieren
Mittel hohe Hitze ist bei mir so ja ich
würde sagen Stufe 7 von 9
schön aufpassen dass er nicht verbrennt
dann kann ich hier schon mal die orange
Früchte in meinem Tiefkühlfach ich weiß
nicht wie es bei euch ist aber ich habe
immer so alle verschiedenen Sorten und
deswegen kann ich so ein Tiramisu
eigentlich immer jederzeit zubereiten
und wenn wir mal Milchprodukte fehlen
wie zum Beispiel Mascarpone da nehme ich
Quark oder Joghurt oder Sahne Schmand
saure Sahne alles was du da ist und es
schmeckt einfach immer gut und
Spekulatius hat man in der Winterzeit
auch immer da das heißt man kann hier
auch so alle möglichen keksreste einfach
nehmen und zu einem schönen Dessert
zubereiten
[Musik]
da fängt es an zu schmelzen
können in der Zeit
ich bin schon eins mit dem Küchenschrank
ne
so mit dem Outfit
ist ja auch so der Küchenschrank
ich kann während der Wartezeit
vielleicht tatsächlich was erklären und
zwar zur induktionsmatte ich habe ja im
ganzen Haus Induktionskochfelder das
bedeutet ja dass da so eine Magnetspule
drin ist und wenn ein Topf drauf ist der
eben magnetisch ist dann funktioniert
das Induktionskochfeld der Vorteil ist
die Platte wird nicht heiß die wird nur
warm durch die rückwärme des Topfes und
das Gute daran ist dass ähm z.B auch
Kinder in der Küche wenn sie mit Kochen
und mitbacken die können sich eigentlich
nicht verbrennen das ist schon mal das
Einhorn Induktion kocht relativ schnell
die Hitze ist da wenn ich sie brauche
und sie ist weg wenn ich sie nicht mehr
brauche das heißt ich habe auch keine
Nachwärme und wir haben dafür extra so
eine induktionsmatte gemacht und zwar
kamen da viele Fragen das ist nämlich
keine Matte die euer Kochgeschirr
induktionsfähig macht denn da ist nichts
magnetisches mit drin sondern das ist
eine matte die euer Induktionskochfeld
schützt vor Kratzern zum Beispiel und
gerade wenn ich so ein Bräter drauf habe
wie jetzt hier diese Gusseisen fahren
und ich habe zum Beispiel ein bisschen
Zucker drunter etwas Pfeffer oder Salz
oder Staubkörner und ich schüttel da die
Pfanne hin und her kannst schon
ausprobieren dass euer
Induktionskochfeld zerkratzt und
deswegen haben wir eine Silikonmatte
gemacht die ist hitzebeständig und eben
rutschfest das habe ich sie nach oben
gebogen das macht aber gar nichts und da
ist einfach der Vorteil dass das
Kochgeschirr dann euren Herd nicht
zerkratzt und das ist eben so ein
induktionsmatte aber da könnt ihr euch
gerne das technikvideo von Murat
anschauen nur habe ich mir gedacht weil
jetzt viele gefragt haben ob das
Kochgeschirr dann induktionsfähig wird
nein und das ist auch nur für Induktion
geeignet denn andere Kochfelder zerran
findet die werden zu heiß und dann ist
das nichts mit deinem Vater
ist wirklich eine Schutzmatte eine
Anti-Rutschmatte und man kann es eben
ganz gut auch nehmen für ein Holzbrett
zum drunter legen damit da einfach
nichts verrutscht sondern universal
Unterlage jetzt karamellisiert hier der
Zucker und ist auch hier völlig normal
dass sie sich nach oben biegt weil der
Topf jetzt nicht oder die Pfanne eben
nicht komplett bis über die ganze Matte
geht und hier habe ich quasi den Druck
drauf hier nicht und deswegen klappt es
nach oben aber das ist das ist gar nicht
schlimm so sobald der Zucker dann so
bernsteinfarben ist wie hier
[Musik]
dann noch etwas Tonka Paste dazu passt
geschmacklich perfekt ihr könnt aber
auch ein bisschen Tonkabohne dazu reiben
und jetzt alles gut aufkochen lassen
denn der Zucker der wird jetzt erstmal
fest durch die kalten Früchte da
stockt einfach nicht er stoppt er wird
einfach fest weil er abkühlt und jetzt
müsste quasi den Zucker einfach so ein
bisschen aufkochen lassen und das ganze
nur kurz köcheln lassen und dann ist die
Füllung schon mal fertig
so die Zeit nimmst du jetzt aber zum
Aufräumen
[Musik]
das kostet bei mir schon etwa vier
Minuten die Früchte haben tatsächlich
sehr viel Wasser und deswegen werde ich
das ganze jetzt noch Abbinden wenn es
bei euch auch so ist einfach einen
Esslöffel Speisestärke mit zwei
Esslöffeln Wasser vermischen und hier
dazu geben kurz aufkochen lassen und
dann könnt ihr die Füllung abkühlen
lassen und dann kann ich nämlich schon
mal die cremige Füllung zubereiten
[Musik]
für die Creme verwende ich 250 Gramm
Quark 250 g Mascarpone 80 Gramm
Puderzucker Vanilleextrakt 400 Gramm
Schlagsahne 50 g Mohn und sanaparte zum
steif schlagen ihr könnt jetzt hier
überlegen ob ihr den Mohn dazu nehmt
oder nicht ich finde es geschmacklich
hammermäßig gut aber ich weiß dass
manche Mohn nicht mögen dann können den
einfach weglassen ich nehme jetzt hier
einfach Quark und Mascarpone die Zutaten
werden kurz mit Puderzucker verrührt
ich finde es auch einfach so ein schönes
schnelles Rezept richtig schön easy
kurz cremig rühren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und fertig die Creme kommt jetzt in den
Kühlschrank ich warte jetzt noch bis die
Bären abgekühlt sind und dann kann ich
alles schon Schichten
[Musik]
jetzt wird's wild ja ich nehme jetzt
eine schöne Form in der ich das Tiramisu
servieren werde das jetzt hier diese und
ich habe jetzt hier meine drei
Komponenten die mohncreme Fruchtkompott
und die Spekulatius Kekse und jetzt
mache ich das ganze echt ein bisschen
wild also ihr könnt gerne mit dem
Spritzbeutel Arbeiten ich habe auf
meinem Kanal auch schon viele Rezepte wo
ich das Tiramisu schön Anrichte aber ich
finde hier nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal
keinen Werkzeug zur Hilfe so und dann
gucken einfach das ist schön und
trotzdem appetitlich aussieht also die
spekulati ist Kekse kommen hier jetzt
einfach rein
nimmt einfach die Form die euch am
besten gefällt
[Musik]
und dann nehme ich jetzt die Hälfte der
mohn- die kommt da drauf
mich da jetzt schon drauf
schön verstreichen
okay schon ein bisschen schwierig was
geht
[Musik]
was soll's wir nehmen die ganze creme
ich habe eine große Ofenform und ich
Schichte das jetzt nur einmal
schön verteilen
was ihr tun könnt ist natürlich unten
drunter noch ein bisschen Fruchtkompott
aber wenn ihr das so gemacht dann
bleiben die Kekse schön knackig weil sie
unten nämlich relativ trocken bleiben
tatsächlich wenn ihr es jetzt demnächste
wird ansonsten Weichen sind natürlich
auch auf durch die durch die Creme
so
dann kommt jetzt das Fruchtkompott drauf
[Musik]
und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach noch ein
paar spekulatius-kekse und legte schön
obendrauf oder jetzt der Krümel sie
darüber ihr könnt es auch Marmorieren
ganz wie ihr möchtet
[Musik]
wenn ihr wollt gebt jetzt noch ein paar
essbare Glitzersteine drüber und fertig
ist euer Tiramisu ich stecke das jetzt
ab es kommt in den Kühlschrank und wenn
es ein bisschen durchgezogen ist dann
kannst serviert werden ist einfach ein
geniales einfaches schnelles Löffel und
wenn das Tiramisu dann durchgezogen ist
könnt ihr es direkt an löffeln
aus der Schüssel heraus
und servieren
Alarm willst du mit mir probieren
also auf jeden Fall bisschen Keks
bisschen Frucht und mutcreme
ich wollte mich so gewalttätig sein
mit allen Komponenten drauf
auch Keks auch Keks
ja hier bitteschön
ich verstehe einfach Menschen nicht die
kein Mohn mögen ich finde das bringt so
so ein Aroma mit rein und eine tolle
Konsistenz
okay ich probiere
deinen Milchshake und Du darfst hier
probieren
wow
ellas Welt
voll lecker ella
ich meine deine Milch die ist voll gut
ja
gibt es das Rezept auf ellas-blog.de
ach gibt's gar nicht
sollst du es mal geben
ja willst du dann Rezepte machen
echt oder willst du lieber
Steuerberaterin werden
[Musik]
oder beides
ach so ich sollte an Weihnachten ein
Tablet kaufen damit du damit Videos
machen kannst
und du brauchst das Tablet dann nicht
zum Spielen oder zocken oder so
und dann
sind wir dann drauf anschauen App machen
zum Lernen und dann
achso okay also du brauchst das Tablet
zum arbeiten ja habe ich es richtig
verstanden zum Arbeiten und Lernen
[Musik]
okay das überlege ich mir das jetzt mal
okay weil du so ehrlich zu mir warst gut
dann kannst du vielleicht folgende Frage
beantworten wo gibt's denn das Rezept zu
diesem Tiramisu
.de perfekt
und hat es dir geschmeckt
sehr schön also auf ella's Empfehlung
hin dürft ihr gerne das Tiramisu
ausprobieren und zu Hause nachmachen ich
würde mich freuen wenn ihr mich auf
euren Bildern verlinkt da kann ich sie
nämlich freeposten also euch noch schöne
Weihnachten und bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]
klar kannst sogar irgendwann mal einfach
so einen Kaffee eröffnen mit so coole
Ideen
okay gut aber wir naschen jetzt nicht
alles ne
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
bis zur süße
kleine Maus
[Musik]